Rob Jenkins life was turned upside down
in 2008 when he was convicted of grand
marijuana in his apartment I don't know
who told on me or what but police ran in
there took my whole art apart trashed
the hall apartment I got evicted from
the apartment I got a notice like two
weeks later said get the hell out
Jenkins managed to avoid jail time with
a plea deal but his criminal record made
it difficult to find a job so he went
back to illegally growing and dealing
marijuana and I had two cellphones and
pretty much risk going back to jail wild
on the probation for three years so it
was pretty much just risking my life
Jenkins is one of an estimated 20
million people nationwide with a
criminal record related to marijuana use
or distribution living in a state where
recreational cannabis is now legal in a
move that's reminiscent of the final
years of the Prohibition era when then
President Franklin Roosevelt issued some
1,300 pardons for alcohol-related
offenses officials are now looking for
ways to clear these convictions from the
public record with a new year come new
laws that take effect today in
California and among them the
legalization of marijuana it's going to
send a beacon of hope out to all of the
other states in to all of the other
countries across the world where
cannabis is still illegal when
California voters legalized cannabis in
2016 they also approved a proposition
that allowed the state to expunge past
convictions but the law hasn't worked as
intended there are too many bureaucratic
hurdles in the path to expungement but
the way the legislation was written and
really kind of put her all the people
that have been convicted yeah it didn't
prohibit us from doing anything about it
but it then also spell out that you
should San Francisco district attorney
George Gascon became aware of this
problem when his office first started
tackling the process of identifying
Records eligible for removal from the
system in 2017 the city had over 9,000
residents eligible for expungement but
only 23 people had petitioned to wipe
their records clean we know that
statewide the numbers of people seeking
relief for this type of stuff is usually
around 5 or 10%
so there's a really small number and
frankly often the people that seek
relief or they're more sophisticated
they understand the law is there they
can hire a lawyer or even if they don't
have the money hire a lawyer to go for
actively to a punishment clinic right
they do this on their own
Roscoe and turned to Silicon Valley for
help partnering with a non profit Code
for America to come up with a
technological solution to the problem of
too much red tape a criminal record is
an enormous barrier to two jobs
to stable housing to education to being
able to engage in your kids school
activities Ivonne Silva is code for
America's senior program director how do
we reduce those barriers and we started
to build an early technology that would
help an individual go through that
process on their own in building that
technology we ask the question well why
do people have to apply at all why
petition at all when we know that the
government has the information to
evaluate eligibility to provide this
relief automatically Silva's group is
aiming to clear a quarter million
cannabis-related convictions in
California by the end of the year it's
using an algorithm to flag records
eligible for expungement then software
automatically files the necessary
paperwork to clear the conviction while
San Francisco was the first county in
the state to implement this new program
Code for America is partnering with
other jurisdictions including Los
Angeles and San Jose to launch a pilot
program it's hoping eventually to apply
its technology nationwide the technology
is actually very simple
but it also starts to shift the way in
which people relate to their government
because now this is a service provided
to government as opposed to government
being seen as an obstacle Jenkins who
now works in the legal cannabis industry
and is hoping to start his own medical
grow operation paid thousands of dollars
in attorney fees to get his conviction
expunged I feel kind of validated you
know I know people are still in jail for
it you know so that so it's legal but
there's still people in jail right now
but cannabis related offenses I know
eventually they might get released and
eventually you know they might have
their record expunged but I mean it's
days lost time lost I lost everything
when I got arrested I was a lot of
resources that I could have used towards
the business I'm
start from scratch right now
[Music]